Here is a beautiful ribber stitch pattern
that was inspired by a hand knitting
pattern called Textured Rib.
It's basically 2x2
ribbing, slipping the knit stitches
to highlight the purl stitches.
More attractive than plain old 2x2
ribbing, it looks great on both sides.
I can't decide which side I like better.
Instead of right and wrong side,
I'm calling these side A and side B.
The pattern is worked over a standard
2x2 needle set up.
Two needles on the ribber,
two needles on the main bed.
Then stitches are slipped every other row.
I chose to slip on my ribber, keeping the
main bed needles in work on every row.
Of course, you could do it the opposite
way, slipping on the main bed
and knitting every row on the ribber.
Now, notice the slip strands
on side B, adding interesting texture.
I hope you'll give this
stitch pattern a try.
If you've struggled with 2x2
ribbing, the cast on can be a bit
of a challenge at first.
We have an entire course
covering everything you need to know.
Knititnow.
com/2x2
Happy Knitting.